every interview that I watched of you
people asked you about I'mma make them
both but a vantage point that we were
missing was Donovan's vantage point so I
asked Donovan to send me a video of his
vantage point of I'mma make it both I
think one of the funniest things was
after he missed he grabbed the net
grabbed out a second one as if like the
rim had moved like it wasn't his fault
he missed both cuz it was like bro like
you done it up already you might as well
just take this out and go go head back
to the bench he's not the first first
person to say that smart said you walked
up to the rim like it moved and I said
in all honesty bro the second free throw
went in and out and I was just mad at
the fact that it just wouldn't fall I
actually yell to Telly brothers and he
was like oh it's not my fault you must
free thr so like that's another added
that no one
knows